Louis Nicolas mesdames messieurs bonsoir
vous connaissez donc Arnaud Montebourg
sofitelman sous la présente pas
effectivement puisque elle s'occupe de
Téléfoot et ça recommence à la rentrée
on est ravis pour elle Alain Laroche
donc vous connaissez la roche mais oui
l'OM ouais j'ai été cité par tapis comme
témoin vous connaissez l'affaire de l'OM
et Doc Gynéco alias Bruno bossir
extraordinaire
voilà alors j'ai le PDG du groupe
Nicolas qui est spécialisé dans
l'enlèvement de déchets urbain et
industriel c'est quand même 875 millions
de francs de chiffre d'affaires
dans de nombreuses grandes villes de
France on va pas les citer mais enfin il
y en a beaucoup et dernièrement alors je
le dis à tous les potes de Doc Gynéco
vous avez gagné l'appel d'offres pour
l'enlèvement des tags à Paris jusqu'à
maintenant chaque fois vous taguez un
mur vous enrichissez Louis Nicolas
alors vous êtes également propriétaire
des tissus provençaux sous les ados vous
allez racheter la famille de mairie de
la manade de Jean Lafont élevage de
taureaux élevage de chevaux moi je
connais tout ça parce que j'ai fait mes
études à Montpellier mais oui je connais
bien les deux mairies je connais bien la
churrascaia et la malade de Jean Lafont
donc c'est des choses voilà mais ça
marche toujours le choix est-ce qu'il y
a une fois par mois une fois par mois
c'est pas beaucoup non à notre époque
c'est tous les samedis oui je sais mais
ça vous amuse pas si ça m'amuse mais
j'attends de Cordy revienne ah Corti
bien et puis vous êtes aussi
propriétaire du Mas Saint-Gabriel donc
domaine
agricole de 800 hectares entre
Montpellier et Lunel bon ça c'est déjà
une chose en plus de ça vous êtes
président du club de foot de Montpellier
qui s'appelle le Montpellier Hérault
Sport Club du club de rugby de Béziers
et du club de basket du PSG voilà donc
voilà Paris Basket Racing ça fait pas
mal ça roule pour vous loulou
ça roule ça roule le basket ça roule pas
trop
nul très nul bien excuse-moi de te
couper avec plaisir mon pote j'ai
quelques copains et qui aimeraient
entrer en centre de formation au foot
ouais mais à Montpellier ils vont
préférer aller à Paris non en D1 en
direct
ensuite ce que je pourrais te donner
leur contact mais avec plaisir tu
viendras nous voir c'est pour apprendre
on rigolera bien ok
bien alors pourtant effectivement au
départ d'ailleurs j'ai besoin de
l'espoir à tout le monde parce qu'au
départ vous avez commencé un petit peu
difficilement maintenant vous êtes
milliardaire vous gérez plein de clubs
de sport et tout ça c'est vous qui fait
pas évident alors on va parler un petit
peu de vous
[Musique]
alors Louis vous êtes né en 1943 à
Valence dans la Drôme j'ai passé votre
enfance à Lyon alors votre père Marcel
était conducteur d'autorail dans les
années 30 et puis un jour il a reçu une
paille d'acier dans dans l'oeil et il a
perdu l'oeil il a quitté évidemment les
chemins de fer et puis la montée une
entreprise de vente et de livraison de
charbon à Lyon dans la banlieue de Lyon
et en 1952 la ville de Lyon a été
paralysée par une greffe des éboueurs
municipaux et le maire de la ville le
célèbre Édouard Herriot a fait appel à
toutes les bonnes volontés et votre père
Marcel a proposé non seulement ces deux
camions mais ses bras et on remerciement
il a obtenu de Edouard Herriot le
ramassage des poubelles à Lyon alors
voilà il a fait fortune après vous avez
été longtemps complexé par le succès de
votre père et vous dites souvent mon
père c'était levé avant moi
mais je pense qu'il faut le reconnaître
dans la vie quand on a un père qui
s'élevait en soi il faut le dire bah
avoir de le dire maintenant vous savez
succéder à un père et garder
l'entreprise
vous êtes très modeste mais en fait
cette entreprise vous l'avez énormément
développé pris confiance à vos fiches
dans de nombreuses villes que je me
citerai pas mais c'est vrai alors ce
scolarité pas terrible
virer de jésuses et tout de suite là tu
rigoles
et puis il s'est retrouvé dans une boîte
à bac pour Ghost de riche le cours
Pascal que des branleurs complet
mais il y en a pas beaucoup qui ont pas
réussi après
évidemment le jeudi vous alliez faire du
foot avec l'équipe du lycée vous avez
rencontré dynalo parce qu'il Redé autour
de Gerland et vous étiez intéressé par
tous les sports à l'époque hein oui j'ai
toujours aimé ça il y avait un magazine
enfin magazine [ __ ] et club et puis
miroir spring Tour de France 3 par
semaine il y avait une grand-mère qui
m'a acheté tout ça et le virus ça m'a
passionné voilà alors les études vont
pas terrible vous avez essayé trois fois
d'avoir le bac vous avez eu finalement
Dreyfus 4 un Dreyfus 4
vous regrettez pas aujourd'hui d'avoir
pas travaillé un petit peu à l'école
quand même d'un regrette toujours parce
que surtout quand on est
en face de gens je vais pas parler des
marques mais
d'ingénieur et tout et c'est vrai que
j'aurais fait des études d'ingénieurs je
pense que quelquefois j'aurais pu placer
un peu mieux mon entreprise sûrement
bien sûr bon enfin tous les cas c'est
comme ça alors votre père et voilà il
vous voit rater les études il vous fait
travailler comme éboueurs et alors vous
dormiez sous le camion ça m'arrivait et
alors son père c'est terrible pour voir
comment il bossait son père il suivait
la benne avec la 400 rouge très juste
et ça ça c'est pas de la rigolade
vous vous surveiller
et là bon ben voilà vous découvrez le
monde du travail ça vous a sans doute
fait du bien vous découvrez les
premières cuites au gros rouge avec le
casse-croûte quoi à quelle heure à 9h du
matin plutôt 7h
non je crois que le meilleur de tout
c'était la douche après le boulot avec
le personnel j'étais quand même le fils
du patron vous étiez du côté des
ouvriers parce que c'est vous qui
demandez les augmentations de salaire
pas tout à fait mais je n'aurais pas été
patron j'aurais été
voilà donc en 77 votre père décroche le
contrat de de Montpellier de Montpellier
et alors à cette époque vous devez vous
marier avec une bise Antine [ __ ] mais
quoi vous savez ça avec une bise Antine
tu es ma femme va pas être contente elle
le sait elle le sait de façon
heureusement que ça s'est passé comme ça
parce que le jour de la note tout était
prêt
c'est mes copines de Saint-Fons qui
m'avait dit tu fais la plus grosse
connerie de ta vie de ton mari pauvre et
comme un con je les ai écoutés comme un
confinement
Colette elle est charmante elle dirait
ado en plus
alors voilà donc vous échappez le jour
du mariage il s'échappe tout à fait une
semaine avant une semaine avant et au
filet à Montpellier
voilà mais avec votre passion du foot
qui est toujours intacte vous travaillez
donc sur l'entreprise de votre père
alors quand j'arrive à Montpellier il y
a pas de club vous faites un club corpo
oui c'est quoi c'est un club des
bouilloire quoi la formation sportive
les poubelles et vous faites un club au
départ c'était Noël qui ramassait les
poubelles puis après on a un peu
amélioré avec la Paillade ça commence en
quelle division tu as commencé où
promotions
parler toujours des vertus paiadines
c'est-à-dire que ça c'est vraiment la
base du système quoi bah oui parce que
c'est un stade c'est un stade de
quartier on a reçu des grandes équipes
en Coupe de France et je reconnais quand
ils arrivaient dans ce quartier de La
Paillade un peu chaud
gitan un peu tout ils avaient un peu
peur je me rappelle de sinaïel avec Metz
je me rappelle la grande épique qui
dévers j'avais un peu chaud et puis on
réalisait quelques exposants des
tribunes en bois en plus 300 personnes
alors parallèlement au développement de
vos affaires vous vous développez le
club et c'est vrai qu'à l'arrivée de
fraîches quand fraîche a été élu à
Montpellier ça vous a donné un coup de
pouce quand même mais c'est plutôt qu'un
74 quand on a démarré le maire de
l'époque Delmas ne voulait rien entendre
du sport et en 77 finalement on a eu la
grande chance d'avoir Georges Frêche qui
d'entrer nous a permis de passer
professionnelle et de mettre la main en
bassinet parce que tout seul comme ça
puis en plus j'ai des potes tout à fait
patron c'est encore mon père
très juste mais rapide
je raconte pas tout mais voilà vous êtes
parti d'un club corpo c'est vrai que
vous avez amené en division quand même
81 division en combien de temps après ça
a pris 14 7 ans le temps du cet état
voilà
alors vous donnez à fond bon là-dedans
dans le foot mais vous n'êtes pas foot
business c'est pour ça que c'est
intéressant que hein la roche soit là
parce que vous vous avez du mal avec le
foot business quoi puis c'est dur même
tout ce que vous avez fait vous les
recherches de sponsor les loges VIP le
merchandising tout ça vous vous avez du
mal est-ce que c'est difficile ou ça
vous intéresse pas à l'entrée en Bourse
pas ça non non non non vous pensez pas
que je me vois pas faire demain du
pognon avec le football voilà c'est ça
le pognon vous le faites dans votre
business mais quand c'est le foot vous
voulez pas mélanger les choses non
au passage là vous en parle c'est quoi
de son affaire là vous avez je pense que
tapis aurait pas fait de politique je
pense qu'il y a des certaines choses qui
ce serait peut-être arrondi ouais ouais
je pense que tapis a un a trouvé
maintenant c'est son droit vous
finalement vous êtes jamais mêlé de
politique
je suis pas sûr du sport mais la
politique vous avez jamais touché vous
non parce que en plus on a un maire à
Montpellier qui ont fait pour vous même
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec lui
politiquement il en fait pour vous à
Montpellier
il y a des hibiscus à Montpellier des
hibiscus
bien sûr
il y a tout à Montpellier bien alors oui
j'ai fait une saison des deux et ça vous
a quand même un peu ça faisait un peu
fait réfléchir oui ça m'a fait un bilan
des erreurs quand même là
sacré paquet de conneries
mais le recrutement c'est vrai qu'à une
époque c'est pas vous que je vais la
prendre mais une époque des recruté
Jules César Cantona enfin vous avez
c'était la bonne époque vous avez emmené
quand même le club
très loin on a gagné en même temps
financièrement c'était cher quoi moins
40 et voilà arrivé alors maintenant je
m'interdis de péter les plombs donc vous
êtes un peu calmé finalement auto calmé
je repartirai peut-être en dérives on
verra
j'ai eu la chance de l'interviewer et
c'était un grand moment je l'ai même
fait mon tas de cheval
alors le sport
le sport le sport vous coûte de l'argent
Louis mais vous en rapporte aussi parce
que le sport comme le foot ça vous ouvre
des portes pour vos affaires non
ça ouvre mais vous savez il y a un sport
qui est au plus l'importe que tout c'est
le rugby c'est le meilleur pour les
affaires oui c'est convivial beaucoup
plus convivial que le football et puis
il y a beaucoup de gens qui parlent vrai
lui je dis pas que dans le football il
parle pas tous vrai mais il y a pas mal
de fautes est-ce que le fait d'être
franc-maçons ça aide dans vos affaires
c'est la blouse violette
ça fait 10 ans je suis toujours apprenti
alors tu vois un peu les fois que j'y
suis allé donc c'est pas la
franc-maçonnerie qui vous aide
faire cesser de voir mes appels les
planches ça ça me fait mal à la tête
c'est toujours aussi ouais vous êtes
comme à Saint-Hélène que vous êtes
toujours aussi réfractaires aux études
que ça soit chez les jésuites
mais bon pour vos affaires il y a le
foot pour la franc-maçonnerie
apparemment c'est pas mon truc mais de
temps en temps
vous avez mis de l'argent vous avez mis
de l'argent dans l'affaire du fils du
maire de Saint-Pierre de la Réunion
d'adjoint de la joie au maire voilà vous
avez mis 200000 francs des poulets
le mec il vend des boîtes à caca
devant le juge à Saint-Pierre de la
Réunion
le juge lui dit et vous Monsieur Nicolas
qu'en pensez-vous et Louis lui répond
ben moi je pense qu'on est pas dans la
merde
vous avez mis 200000 balles dans une
affaire du fils de la géomètre
Saint-Pierre de la Réunion en pensant
que ça allait vous aider pour vos
affaires Louis je dis la vérité bah oui
mais ici oui on n'est pas au tribunal
moi je dis toujours la vérité
ouais ça vous aide c'est pire que Baffie
toi
tapis vous avez fait citer comme témoin
à son procès pourquoi pour dire que tous
les clubs faisaient la même chose que
disent la roche tout à l'heure non pas
du tout je pense qu'il va inciter parce
qu'on avait fait la Coupe d'Europe en
même temps que l'OM
et il voulait me faire parler comme quoi
on donnait des cadeaux aux arbitres des
repas donc ça coûtait excessivement cher
je pense que j'ai pas eu le temps parce
que dans la vie quand un gars est dans
la merde je pense qu'on se doit d'y
aller et on doit être solidaire bon j'y
suis allé ça s'est bien passé à la fois
mal passé parce que moi je riais le
Président il rigolait pas
je me suis fait filer un carton rouge
quand même
vous en pensez quoi Arnaud Montebourg de
toutes ces histoires du foot vous mais
que une tradition du football
populaire enraciné est en train de
d'être menacé par l'arrivée l'objectif
de du football capitalistique moi j'ai
une petite j'ai une petite équipe et
loue en Cuiseaux qui souffre je connais
bien le prix de président Jacky Duriez
qui est votre homologue et qui et qui se
battent c'est un football du de
territoire de l'identité d'un territoire
ils sont laminés pas par pas seulement
par l'argent mais aussi par le pouvoir
sportif qui accompagne finalement la
concentration des moyens mise à la
disposition des clubs nous on est passé
comme l'eau en Cuiseaux dans ces
divisions là voilà donc je peux pas
raisonner comme les autres voilà non
mais j'ai compris où vous étiez j'ai
compris vous vous pensez quoi du
classement de D1 qui va changer
à cause à cause de la de la plante de
Toulouse on casse les couilles
à Toulouse pour que ça s'arrange il
reste à Créteil il est à Bordeaux
ça c'est impossible bien alors comme
vous le remarquez ce soir c'est
peut-être l'influence de Sophie telman
c'est un spécial Téléfoot qu'on fait là
c'est incroyable une influence sur moi
c'est incroyable
elle est mignonne
bien Louis Nicolas on va vous faire une
interview technicolore
[Applaudissements]
très simple que cette technologie
qu'est-ce qui vous rend Louis Nicolas
verderrage verdorage des fêtes qu'est-ce
qui vous rend rouge dehors
quand je parle mal
les gros mots ouais ça arrive quand même
sur les bandes
qu'est-ce qui vous rend bleu de peur
de descendre en des deux
qu'est-ce qui vous rend rose de bonheur
rose de bonheur de regagner la Coupe de
France
Merci
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu